the kids cash in that's the focus of
tonight's angle the British royalty has
always been like cocaine to the press
they can never get enough of it in the
tabloid era it was Princess Diana then
William and Kate but there seems to have
been a whole new level of adoration
reserved for Prince Harry and his wife
Megan Markel for the global elites the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex was a
long-awaited cure-all for everything
that was wrong in the stuffy stuck-on
protocol royal family appreciates our
planet and what it has to offer
the world we live in cannot be
replicated or tamed feminism is about
fairness the basic and fundamental human
right of being able to participate in
the choices for your future and that of
your community as a biracial woman
marrying into an institution seen by so
many as a bastion of white privilege and
a symbol of the abuses of colonialism
Megan Marco has quickly been adopted as
a beacon of potential change here Wow
but after months of complaining that
they actually hadn't been accepted by
the Royals Harry and Megan dropped a
bombshell didn't even call the Queen and
they did it via Instagram insisting that
we intend to step back as senior members
of the royal family and work to become
financially independent while continuing
to support Her Majesty the Queen in
other words we're not gonna do what's
expected of us but we're happy to cash
in on the whole royal thing they want to
collaborate with the Queen and Prince
Charles and Prince William rather than
having this system where they have to be
told what to do all the time on that
sounds like my kids they don't want to
do what they're supposed to do they just
want to keep getting Frieza all right
well they want the benefits of being a
prince and a princess but they see
themselves more like jay-z and Beyonce
than Will and Kate or Duke and Duchess
now there are reports that they've even
trademarked their titles or want to as
they wait for what their baby boy to
determine his own gender identity well
they're gonna live a transcontinental
life likely in Canada and in England but
May
no mistake they'll still live off the
royal family and when in the UK they'll
continue to reside at the palatial home
gifted to them by the Queen and
refurbished especially for them courtesy
of the British taxpayers the royal
family is still reeling from Prince
Andrew's connection with Jeffrey Epstein
is reportedly appalled by the duo's
ungrateful boorish behavior but don't
worry Harry and Megan are starting a
charitable foundation to help you little
people well we in the u.s. ever all know
royal wannabes don't we they also enjoy
exploiting their former positions for
piles of cash of course I'm talking
about the Clintons they entered the
White House in 92 worth nothing but by
the time they got settled into private
life Bill Clinton was worth 240 million
dollars
did that many people really buy their
lousy memoirs that's on top of what they
raised through the Clinton Foundation
which took in 249 million in Hillary
Clinton's first year as Secretary of
State hmm well they conveniently then
grafted their daughter Chelsea into the
scam by naming her vice chair of the
foundation we are probably most well
known for our work in healthy we also
work in climate change we work on
empowering women and girls around the
world particularly supporting women
entrepreneurs around the world from
Haiti to West Africa to India
well Chelsey is a woman best known for
her last name with no discernible
professional experience I'm sure she's a
nice person but she also made nine
million dollars since 2011 by just
sitting on the board of an Internet
investment firm run by her mom's friend
and that's not all for her non-existent
experience in broadcast journalism
she was also paid twenty six thousand
seven hundred twenty four dollars per
minute as a special correspondent for
NBC again despite having zero broadcast
experience or media talent now she's a
best-selling children's author
occasionally sharing writing credit with
that other beloved children's scribe her
mother Hillary Clinton I will say I do
talk to my mother more now that I have
made her a grandmother I have definitely
worth millions of dollars for that dog
pony show well look it's a routine
copied by former Vice President Joe
Biden's favorite son hunter middle-class
Joe went from having possibly negative
net worth turning more than 15 million
bucks since leaving office and his son
seems to have learned the secret of
success nepotism hunter Biden raked in
$50,000 a month of course as a member of
that Ukrainian gas company buries m'a
despite having no energy experience at
all and we still don't know how hunter
benefited from his business deals in
China how much he benefited but
according to the Biden loving media it's
the Trump children who are the real
problem the Trump kids almost every day
they probably make more money than
hunter died and made in all of his years
in serving investors in public and
companies abroad so certainly a hunter
Biden was not the first one and you just
look at the trick now a couple of the
Trump kids probably the most unethical
group of people that we've ever seen in
this republic here's a problem the Trump
kids didn't get rich off being in public
office they actually had made their
money before their breath the president
was elected it came from running
something called a business okay making
a payroll in fact the president by some
accounts has lost money since taking
office maybe as much as a billion
dollars his businesses which his kids
run are suffering some of them some of
the properties and resorts are
reportedly losing some money but the
media tell us it's the Trump kids who
need to be watched and held in suspicion
that's kind of a nifty trick isn't it I
guess the Trump kids need to go bankrupt
in order to pass the ethics test of the
left meanwhile liberals with family
connections and cool humanitarian ideas
but zero Talent they get to cash in and
get a free pass and that's the angle